confirmed results that jensaki the press
secretary just announced from the white
house that she has contracted kovid
19 and that she was just tested positive
she's had two socially distance meetings
with the president in recent days
so not a direct contact via their
statement but she will not be traveling
she just announced with the president to
his on his trip to europe this week john
and that's the second time exactly the
same thing has happened remember a
number of months ago she had coveted as
well she said she tested
negative up until one day when she
suddenly tested positive i think it was
on a saturday that she tested positive
and she
for went a uh a trip uh at that point
but it just goes to show that you know
we haven't had a lot of news about covet
lately but it remains an issue in this
country with the ba2 variant now
circulating in europe and probably
circulating here already as well we can
expect that covid is going to remain on
the radar screen for some time to come
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else